[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui par
skype
enki bilal ses dessins ses peintures et
même des images de ces films seront
exposés du 18 juillet au 4 janvier ou
capucins de landerneau et il vient de
publier nu avec picasso aux éditions
stock
je recevrai ensuite un spécialiste des
animaux sauvages alain sennepin qui va
nous raconter l'incroyable victoire des
cachalots dans leur guerre contre les
baleiniers au 19e siècle
et oui il ya eu une guerre du pacifique
que les baleines ont remporté
collectivement contre les hommes
essaient de cette guerre que par le moby
dick le roman de melville mais
commençons par nu avec picasso bonjour
enki bilal il s'agit d'une des récits
assez surréaliste un illustré par par
quelques dessins vont voir d'ailleurs
derrière moi et qui se passe alors
pendant le confinement
quand on le lit on peut en avoir
l'impression vous à les rectifier dans
un instant mais comment l'avez vous vécu
ce confinement
parce que moi quand je les j'ai vécu à
paris et j'ai eu parfois l'impression
d'être dans un dessein de bilal un peu
comme le dessin qui va qui va s'afficher
derrière moi et qu'on pourra voir à
landerneau voilà c'était un peu comme ça
le le confinement
il y avait quelque chose de désertifier
de figer vous même est ce que vous avez
est ce que vous aviez l'impression
d'avoir anticipé quelque chose comme
cela
alors je n'ai pas eu l'impression m'a
susurré ces appareils aussi mais je n'ai
pas eu l'impression d'être dans un de
mes dessins dans un univers on va dire
mais il y avait quelque chose alors là
c'est étrangement qui me faisait penser
les deux trois premiers jours quand je
sortais je pensais à sarajevo au temps
de la guerre en l'éclatement de la
yougoslavie dans les années 90 à
sarajevo et je me disais voilà des gens
un moment sortait comme ça dans des rues
désertes et jusqu'au moment où on leur a
dit attention il ya des snipers et là
moi la première personne que j'ai
croisés c'était une femme qui promenait
un chien c'était très tôt le matin et la
traversée de trottoir pour ne pas me
croiser de trop près j'ai compris moi
aussi j'ai pas trop osé la regarder et
on se disait voilà peut-être qu'ils
n'aillent peur qui est un virus qui va
le frapper
c'est très étrange ce qu on se fabrique
comme cinéma à ce moment-là ça dure ce
serait pas pas longtemps pas longtemps
mais en même temps on avait un sentiment
d'entrer en
r quelque part on n'a jamais connu de
guerre nous mais je me dis qu'une guerre
ça commence par des situations larrazet
comme ça on dit faut pas sortir
attention il faut prendre un papier vous
dit à quelle heure vous sortez jusqu'à
quelle heure vous êtes qui et puis bon
on s'est dit ça a disparu évidemment
parce que finalement il ya eu tellement
de 2,2 d'erreur tellement de fausses
pistes que finalement tout ça c'est
devenu presque assez assez assez
grotesque il y avait dans votre dernier
album s'appelle bugs
en fait j'ai l'impression que le
confinement c'est l inverse exactement
de bugs tadic dans bug c'est l
informatique qui s'arrêtait internet
toutes les données disparaissait pendant
qu'on finance et l inverse tout s'est
arrêté sauf l'informatique exactement ça
c'est un revers complètement surprenant
étonnant mais en même temps j'avais déjà
pensé comme beaucoup d'auteurs et de
science fiction et passait pas forcément
et simplement à une pandémie c'est un
sujet qui traîne depuis très longtemps
dans l'esprit des gens des auteurs des
écrivains et mais je n'ai jamais voulu
l'aborder parce que je trouve
extrêmement tragique extrêmement
déprimant sans aucune distance possible
alors qu'une bug informatique permet
cette distance précisément parce que on
est tellement addict et que c'est un
effet boomerang et c'est à dire on est
heureux en ce moment avec cette une
seule cet univers numérique on en
profite on en use et on abuse et
finalement si ça nous revient en
boomerang ça devient presque presque
amusant étrangers c'est une analyse
intéressante à faire et donc
effectivement le numérique a sauvé sans
doute des vies parce que d'un
confinement on imagine ce que ses dents
quand on est mal logés dans paris
heureusement qu'il ya ces petits écrans
qui ont permis peut-être de respirer
revenons à nu avec picasso alors ça
commence par une main qui vous pousse
une manne que vous identifiez pas et
alors je disais j'ai l'impression que ça
se passe en confinement parce que vous
êtes sortis pour acheter faire des
achats de première nécessité vous parlez
de votre de votre peinture bien entendu
vous dit qu'à sa personne autour de vous
donc je me dis c'est pendant le
confinement et puis à cette main qui
vous pousse donc vous une porte qui se
referme et vous voilà emprisonnés
dans ce qui ce qu'on va réaliser on va
comprendre qu'il s'agit du musée picasso
mais il se trouve que ce livre vous en
aviez parlé il ya plus d'un an
maintenant dans l'émission que j'anime
sur europe 1 vous m'aviez raconter
l'histoire y avait pas de confinement
alors est-ce que vous avez corrigé de 3
petits trucs au départ avant de le faire
imprimer ou est ce que vous aviez
imaginé qu'un jour il y aurait personnes
autour de vous dans paris alors que vous
allez acheter des faire des achats de
première nécessité à savoir de la
peinture non non c'est vraiment y'a j'ai
rien retouché absolument rien mais cet
isolement imaginer c'était en fin de
compte pour mieux aborder le sujet du
livre est le sujet du livre c'est la
création mais je me retrouve propulsé
dans un endroit je pense que c'est ce
qui s'appelle pp donc de l'être la
lettre p deux fois donc je pensais que
c'était une prison politique parce que
touche il ya un condensé de musée pablo
picasso et en fin de compte voilà c'est
une rencontre alors rêvé fantasmé
évidemment déjanté aussi un avec picasso
qui est dans les yeux avec dora maar qui
l'accompagnent puisque c'est au moment
de la création de guernica la fameuse
gigantesque peinture à laquelle a
assisté
dora maar il ya un invité surprise je
vais pas dire qui c'est et puis à moi
qui suis peut-être l'objet
d'expérimentations quelque part est donc
en fin de compte on est on se retrouve
tous à poil dans cet endroit à poil
pourquoi parce que finalement la nudité
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est le point
de départ de la création artistique vous
dire qu'à lui mal pour c'est pour moi le
sujet le plus important est l'humain
évidemment débarrasser de tout ce qui
est anecdotique à savoir rythmant
pilosité et c'est donc on est nu et on
se voit et donc le délire est réel
pendant l'écriture et lorsque j'ai relu
le livre il ya peu de temps pour
vérifier
eh bien je crois maintenant presque que
j'ai vécu cette histoire pour de vraies
fautes et vous avez vraiment passé une
nuit dans le musée picasso un musée
picasso qui est dans le 4e
arrondissement à paris qui est un très
très beau lieu on va le on va le voir
c'est en y passant une nuit c'est de
paraît d'ailleurs dans une collection
que s'intitule une nuit au musée
c'est sept ans et on y passera une nuit
que vous avez écrit ce livre
mais alors c'est aussi une réflexion sur
le dehors et sur le dedans et ça aussi
c'est très prémonitoire par rapport à un
confinement
oui c'est vrai mais moi même là je suis
assez surpris de ça de cette
concomitance comme ça dehors et dedans
alors dans un premier temps le dehors
d'où je viens de je suis d'où je suis
propulsé à savoir ceux de paris où j'ai
il n'y a pas âme qui vive à 50 mètres à
la ronde donc c'est ce que j'ai dit au
départ et donc je suis propulsé dans ce
dedans et puis très vite on comprend il
a lancé un livre aussi qu'il y ait
beaucoup centré sur l'aspect un peu
impressionnistes comme dire tout ce
qu'on ressent le coach de l'usl factice
le côté sensorielle voilà que c'est un
livre assez sensorielle dès le départ ch
et et finalement le sujet c'est quelque
part le dehors et le dedans
le dedans étant le lieu où la création
se fait c'est à dire de l'intérieur des
individus dans leur tête et leur culture
et donc je me trouve confronté face à
aa3 monstre à ce sont trois artistes à
dora maar coran est une artiste absolue
je préfère peut-être même certaines
oeuvres dora maar à celle de picasso
et puis il ya l'inde était l'invitée
goya et et en fin de compte le dehors
c'est l'endroit d'où je suis où je
retourne je suis de nouveau propulsé je
suis foutu dehors de ceux de dents et
neuf pour aller dans le dehors qui est
la ville d'où je viens c'est à dire
paris et en fin de compte c'est
exactement la similitude qui peut y
avoir entre la création le dehors c'est
ce qui représente notre notre société
notre lieu de naissance notre famille
notre culture bref tout ce qui nous
apprennent et le dedans c'est ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on commence à vouloir créer
alors vous allez vous retrouver à
dessiner ou plutôt à redessiner des
oeuvres de picasso puisque la première
sur lesquels vous tombez c'est la femme
au vase qui se trouve alors à la fois
sur la tombe de picasso 1 mais aussi au
musée reina sofia à madrid et au musée
picasso
alors la voici redessinée par par enki
mais vous allez vous retrouver à
redessiner puisqu'au moment où vous
découvrez picasso il est en train de
dessiner le meurtre stade r l'assassinât
de marat par charlotte corday
là aussi vous allez intervenir à tel
point même que c'est peut-être vous qui
êtes mara dans l'histoire c'est le côté
surréaliste mais vous allez vous vous
remettre à redessiner le charlotte
corday plongeon son couteau dans le
corps de mara vous coltiner la les
oeuvres picasso c'est vous coltiner
picasso en tant qu'artiste c'est plus
seulement un type tout nu dans un buse
et la nuit 1
c'est vrai mais peut-être de l'avoir mis
tout nu en fout en face de moi me donner
une forme de commandites d'assurance 1
on était à égalité
toutes proportions gardées dans tous les
points à tous points de vue mais à ce
que je veux dire c'est aussi c'est que
c'est un jeu c'est assez ludique un jeu
alors je conçois je sais parfaitement
qui est picasso mais je n'ai pas non
plus voulu trop me documenter j'ai voulu
vraiment faire un livre sensorielle y
compris dans mes liens avec cet artiste
donc ce sont des liens de d'artistes
artiste un chacun apprécie le travail de
l'autre ou pas on sait parfaitement que
picasso y avait une grande admiration
pour goya
là je laisse entendre que goya ne
l'aurait pas eue s'il avait connu voilà
mais c'est mon point de vue donc je
prête sa gouaille a peut-être que je le
prête un peu à moi même mais mais en
tout cas voilà c'était c'est un livre à
la fois jubilatoire et libre sur sur la
création et sur ce moment où je me suis
mis au niveau bas au niveau de goya et
de picasso et de dora maar mais vous
dites que goya dont est probablement pas
admirer picasso c'est probable il aurait
pensé que picasso peignait très mal mais
c'est justement ça qui est assez
fascinant c'est de savoir que l'art
progresse ou en tout cas évolué à sa
propre vitesse la peinture abstraite vue
par vue par un pâtre du début du 19e
siècle c'est incompréhensible et la
peinture de picasso est incompréhensible
pour goya
tout à fait d'accord absolument d'accord
les dotant il faut préciser aussi que
picasso a été un très grand dessinateur
aussi donc c'est pas c'est pas
mais simplement c'est une pique à soc
qui ce qui caractérise aussi ça sont à
lancer sa carrière c'est sa longévité
c'est son côté socialos irritation
jouets etc sont c'est sa liberté quelque
part et faire exploser les codes avec
autant d'audace et c'est finalement
c'est peut-être sa meilleure création et
c'est énorme
quelle influence a eu picasso sur vous
il y en at il eu d'abord est ce que vous
leur cracher pour reprendre une
expression vous utilisez dans le livre
ou picasso explique qu on recrache les
artistes qu'on a admiré lui recrache à
sa bannière grillât puisqu'il et
admirait énormément goya est ce que vous
vous recracher du picasso est ce que
vous recracher du goya forcément je
pense que voilà c'est ça l'idée section
se nourrit les uns des autres et comme
la la temporalité me donne une post
position est liée au fait de dire
privilégier celui dernier a recraché
je suis dernier a parlé je suis dernier
à pouvoir les regarder
je les juge pas un jeudi que j'adore
j'adore goya et que j'admire picasso
j'adore son parcours mais mais
effectivement on se nourrit tous les uns
les autres s'amusent dans la théorie il
ya relativement simples mais
relativement et airelles je pense et le
dehors et dedans c'est aussi un peu le
ce qui nous caractérise tous
l'engagement politique faisant partie de
ceux doropo qui vient nous qui vient
nous chercher et qui est venu chercher
picasso à un moment clé de l'histoire du
20e siècle au moment de la montée de vue
du fascisme en europe dans les années 30
et au moment notamment de ceux guernica
bombarder cette ville guide bombardée
par les nazis et d une seule ligne 1 et
les franquistes et que qui deviendra un
peu la marque de fabrique de
l'engagement de picasso comme vous les
dictateurs sont à peu votre marque de
fabrique aussi
enki bilal
vous aurez décidé quelques-uns des
meilleurs la revoici dans dans ce musée
picasso où vous êtes nu à côté de de
picasso et de dora maar les les
dictateurs c'est quelque chose alors à
des dictateurs comme les vôtres c'est
compréhensible probablement par picasso
il vit au 20e siècle mais probablement
pas par goya lui il s'est affrontée à
napoléon ii mais ça n'a rien à voir
ça n'a rien à voir mais c'était son
dictateur à lui je pense est en tout cas
ce qui est pour revenir à cette
obsession de la dictature c'est pas une
obsession c'est une réalité
et effectivement comme picasso créé
guernica en réaction à un fascisme des
dictatures montante
je me suis amusé cette chose que j'ai
été chercher ce bts qui est ce que
picasso n'a pas un jour dessinée fait un
croquis un portrait de hitler je cherche
je ne vois pas ce tombe sur staline par
continent elle fait alors hitler du coup
je dis je vais en faire un à la manière
de picasso donc il est dans le livre ce
portrait d'hitler et j'essayais de faire
croire à certains que c'était et picasso
aider certains ont cru et et le cantal
quant à staline ça c'est très
intéressant c'est une histoire que je ne
connaissais pas à la mort de staline au
53 aragon à la demande des partis
communistes français
aragon de moins d'applications qui était
son ami lui demandent est ce que tu peux
pas nous faire un portrait de staline un
grand homme vient de s'éteindre donc on
applaudit tous eu le grand homme et
puisqu'elle se dit d'accord et il fait
donc un portrait l'eydap d'un staline
jeunes avec moustache c'est vrai mais
s'en sentent où toutes les spécificités
physiques qui font que que staline aura
une stature aura une espèce d'image qui
traversera malheureusement on va dire le
temps et donc il est ce dessin est
parfaitement rejeté retoqué par le parti
communiste et aragon est chargé de de
dire à son ami que le dessin ne convient
pas
c'est une anecdote je trouve assez assez
savoureuse oui et le dessin a
véritablement fait scandale on en parle
un peu encore aujourd'hui comme son sa
fameuse colomb de lapin qu'il
ressemblait un pigeon
mais c'est à d'autres c'était un autre
et ça se joue bien on peut peut pas lui
reprocher ça parce que sinon est ce qu
est ce que la femme au vase ressemble à
son modèle je suis pas sûr de la même
manière alors justement le le le fait
que vous soyez enfermé moi je trouvais
que c'était aussi une métaphore du
confinement
même si je savais que vous l'aviez écrit
avant le fait de vous retrouver enfermé
vous enki bilal dans un musée avec
picasso goya et doha namar nu
c'est une métaphore du confinement pour
moi oui tout à fait t'as fait ça a été
mais moi j'ai vu des trials j'ai vu des
images de confinement est beaucoup plus
déprimante où les gens prennent en
survêtement et ans et on pantoufler en
chevrons des choses assez déprimante en
chaussettes
je pense qu'il vaut mieux à ce moment-là
traîner à poil chez soir fouet à propos
de pose d'ailleurs ce sont les mêmes
laissez vous entendre dans ce récit ce
sont les mêmes en fait qui poserait à
toutes les époques pour les grands
peintres
en gros on va voir là c'est juste
derrière moi cette femme qui est en
train de poser pour picasso peignant
guernica vous donner son nom et et goya
la reconnaît dit mais elle a posé pour
moi en russie et comme vous l'avez
dessinée elle a posé également pour vous
vous même d'ailleurs allé poser pour
picasso pour guernic vous pensé et je me
suis dit que l'idée était séduisante au
fond ce sont toujours les mêmes qui pose
pour le caravage pour picasso est
peut-être aujourd'hui pour pour bilal
mais je me souviens maintenant ça me
revient j'ai posé pour goya aussi c'est
vrai j'aurais aussi pour l'homme de la
grotte de lascaux toujours les mêmes non
mais vraiment j'aime beaucoup que vous
interprétiez cette idée comme ça j'aime
bien ça effectivement cette idée là je
trouve ça assez assez touchant à ses
mouvements en fait c'est l'homme et la
femme c'est le corps humain c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure pour moi le
sujet le plus important de l'art
contemporain ou pas de tous les arts de
vienne eu des temps c'est effectivement
l'humain l'humain et du coup aussi de
vivant alors après il ya l'animal il ya
les pires pressé ouvert sur
l'hybridation sur l'homme et l'animal la
mécanique parfaite de dire c'est
vraiment on a divergé mais c'était on
était quand même conçu pour survivre
dans des conditions particulières
difficile délicate et tout ça c'est la
beauté de la de la vie donc c'est la
beauté de l'art je pense que ça reste
est ok alors que effectivement que ce
soit on imagine que ce soit des mêmes
qui traverse le temps et qui pose pour
la ja même abb qui a posé pour pour tous
et je sais pas me la joue la montre il a
quel âge il a maintenant mais à mon avis
doit continuer à poser oui et alors vous
allez dire on a beaucoup pas les hommes
on a beaucoup pas les animaux mais on
n'a surtout pas les femmes
au fond c'est la femme qui trône sur le
podium
à la fois de la pause et de la
représentation peut-être parce qu'ils
aient plus de peintres sommes très
grande majorité
ça aurait été intéressant de savoir s'il
y avait eu énormément de femmes dans
l'histoire de l'art de la peinture s'il
n'aurait pas fait poser des hommes à
poil aussi triste oui pourquoi vous
connaissez près cette confrontation avec
picasso avec goya avec dora maar qu'est
ce que vous a appris sur vous alors sur
moi je pense que c'est énormément de
choses qui sont pas encore sorti que
j'arrive pas je vais pas chercher à
analyser mais pour parce que pour la
première fois de ma vie je fais un livre
sans me rendre compte que je le fais
c'est à dire c'est quelque chose qui est
arrivé à un moment où une proposition
j'ai dit oui j'ai passé cette nuit un
mois après deux mais je me mets à écrire
et sans savoir ce que je vais écrire
donc il ya quelque chose qui de qui est
de l'ordre de la de la licence bon je
vois quelque chose naître sous mes mains
sous plaisir de l'écriture et du dessin
ce que je ne connais pas d'habitude je
travaille je pense à un sujet je le
développe je viens vrai travail de mise
en mise en perspective donc ça n'a rien
à voir donc c'est prémédité et là c'est
absolument pas prémédité et du coup ça
m'a appris une chose c'est sûr plaisir
de l'écriture parce qu'elle est là il
est débarrassé delà de tout ce qui est
visuel purement visuel dans mes bandes
dessinées où l'image est très importante
lassé des croquis simple qui viennent
émailler le propos donc ça m'a appris
simplement j'avais l'impression d'avoir
x extrait mon style et de l'avoir mise
en en forme pour quelque chose de deux
compacts et d'efficace donc ça m'a
appris beaucoup de choses sur le plaisir
de l'écriture on va revenir sur votre
style en envoyant quelques quelques-unes
de vos planches qui vont être exposés à
landerneau à partir de cet été mais
juste une dernière question puisque vous
avez passé une nuit au musée picasso est
ce que c'était dans le noir est ce que
musée était totalement éclairé ou est-ce
que vous baigner dans une obscurité un
peu similaire à celle de votre récit
voilà quand on est seul dans un musée
j'imagine que vous étiez seul
comment ça se passe alors j'étais
effectivement seules les lumières se
sont amusés vraiment lumière tamisée
il fallait fallait qu'on puisse voir les
heures je pense hélas je n'avais pas eu
l'occasion de le demander et je n'ai vu
personne évidemment
mais je pense que c'est un peu la
lumière peut-être de 2 comment dire une
lumière de ta tante et là le côté
tamisée convenait parfaitement
suffisamment jeu pour voir des oeuvres
déjà les loueurs bien sûr et en même
temps pour mettre comme ça dans un état
particulier alors il est vrai que moi
ensuite je retranscris quelque chose
d'une autre une toute autre réalité
mais ce qui est ce qui me frappe
maintenant quand même c'est que en
maintenant j'ai presque l'impression que
j'ai je vais raconter une histoire vraie
j'ai l'impression d'avoir vécu ça c'est
ça qui est étrange c'est peut-être
précisément parce que ça n'a pas été
préméditée et que ça a été créé comme ça
dans une espèce de d'urgence
parfaitement confortable mais et que
finalement le fait que n'ayant pas de
recul par rapport à un bon
fonctionnement habituel
le fait de produire quelque chose dans
ces conditions là n'auront presque plus
réel venons en à l'exposition qui vous
est consacré à landerneau par le fonds
et l'année edouard leclerc pour la
culture c'est donc aux capucins de
landerneau à partir du 18 juillet et
jusqu'au 4 janvier on va pouvoir y voir
des oeuvres comme celle ci qui est qui
est derrière moi
non pas que vous parliez de votre style
il est il est là pour moi à votre style
tout entier dans des images comme comme
celle ci c'est votre première grande
exposition personnelle grande respecte
yves enki bilal jetons bruit c'est la
plus importante la plus grande dit rien
et une série que j'aime beaucoup qui
était au musée des arts et métiers mais
qui était plus plus axé sur noté m des
thématiques s'était pas tout à fait la
même chose
le louvre c'était aussi une autre
histoire mais là non c'est vraiment la
grande première rétrospective dans un
lieu qui est absolument magnifique et
extrêmement prestigieux qui a accueilli
des artistes magnifique dont je prends
la suite de de velickovic qui était un
ami et qui malheureusement a disparu de
manière incroyable
et voilà donc c'est une c'est une vraie
grande exposition donc vous avec des
thématiques et des mises en perspective
avec d'autres artistes du passé
précisément donc non mon nouvel ami goya
donc il ya mais aussi bacon que vous
citez également dans le livre il ya il
ya pas mal effectivement de comparaison
voit qu'ils vous ont influencé un
réellement comme comme picasso on
s'apercevait qu'il avait été influencé
lors de l'exposition picasso et ses
maîtres ont voyez comment il s'était
confronté lui même à des gens comme goya
justement revenons sur le style vous
êtes certainement à ddd dessinateur
qu'est le plus influencé notre vision du
futur est-ce que vous en êtes conscient
oui je oui parce qu'on me le dit et que
les cubains mais surtout je pense parce
que tout ce que j'ai fait pour l'instant
a été visible a été vue a été lui donc
je cette chance énorme
et puis surtout aussi parce que ce que
je ce que des sujets que je traitais des
des sujets qui regardait vers la vente
devant qui regardaient dans notre
d'enoch dans nos années à venir pas pas
forcément loin justement plus il faut
l'intérêt c'est que ce soit relativement
proche pour être crédible mais ça c'est
un point de vue que j'ai toujours que
j'ai toujours eu et que j'ai toujours
voulu développer dans l'expression
artistique
ça me paraît être ça ça me paraît être
un peu le parent pauvre de la culture
française peut-être justement parce que
la langue est tellement belle que elle
elle n'en finit pas de s'épuiser sur le
passé et le présent donc moi j'ai pris
la liberté de m'épuiser d'accuser cette
langue sur sur eux sur une vision du
futur
oui aller à tel point alors quelque
chose qui pour moi caractérise votre
stylet on le voit bien dans l'image qui
est derrière nous c'est que les l'époux
de vos personnages sont comme de la
matière
ça pourrait être quand vous dessinez un
homme ou une femme parfois c'est comme
si vous décidez un mur
c'est l'impression qu'on a quand on les
regarde oui c'est mais moi c'est la
pression c'est une paille la pression
mais c'est un choix qui s'est fait
naturellement
il ya une unité de texture c'est vrai
dans tout ce que je dessine peint un mur
c'est effectivement peu à voir là au
toucher de ressembler à une peau et
inversement une plante la mer l'océan je
vois là donc ça c'est un unité de
licques de textures unités de lumière
aussi j'ai pris un certain type de chou
c'est des choix qui se sont imposés à
moi pour éviter l'anecdote précisément
cette histoire de nudité ça va dans ce
sens ça aussi c'est comme par exemple
les cheveux les chevelures moi c'est
quelque chose que j'ai de plus en plus
de mal à à peindre parce qu'une
chevelure sa marque
selanne et docte l'anecdote d'une époque
d'un style d'une mode et tout ça ça
finit par brouiller la visibilité de
l'humain
donc depuis même la nudité toute pure ça
aussi ça ramène à quelque chose de
bibliques et du coup j'ai besoin aussi
de faire de ceux des secondes peaux même
les coiffures ce sont des seconde peau
sur le crâne donc donc ça ce sont des
choses que je ressens et que j'ai besoin
de montrer merci à bilal l'exposition se
tiendra du 18 juillet au 4 janvier à
landerneau au fond hélène et et edouard
leclerc pour la culture est nue avec
picasso est édité chez stock dans la
collection une nuit au musée on se
retrouve juste après la pause avec alain
scène peint qui va nous raconter
l'incroyable victoire des cachalots dans
leur guerre contre les baleiniers au 19e
siècle
un sujet qui pourrait inspirer enki
bilal a bientôt haine qui prévaut sujet
remercie
[Musique]
je reçois maintenant un spécialiste des
animaux sauvages c'est alassane pain qui
publie aux éditions de long d'un livre
aux titres sensationnels l'incroyable
victoire des cachalots dans leur guerre
contre les baleiniers au 19e siècle
alors voilà une thèse originale il y
aurait eu d'après vous une véritable
guerre du pacifique entre 1820 et 1860
entre les américains et les baleines et
ce sont les baleines qui l'ont gagné et
elle en gagne et non pas parce qu'elles
étaient les plus fortes mais parce
qu'elles étaient les plus intelligentes
alors vous allez nous raconter ça mais
d'abord je m'aperçois que je parle de
baleines quand vous parlez de cachalot
il faudrait qu'on fasse la différence
entre les ballets délicate celle où il
se trouve qu en anglais c'est le même
mot c'est wayne mais il ya quand même
des cachalots et des baleines vous avez
préféré employer le mot cachalot laura
n'assène pas c'est quoi la différence
entre les deux on voit une balle est d
un cachalot
est-ce que vous pouvez nous résumer la
différence oui
le cachalot c'est le plus grand des
baleines à dents des cétacés à dents ce
qu'on appelle les baleines
ce sont les baleines à fanons en réalité
donc vous avez deux grands groupes de
cétacés les cétacés à dents dont le plus
grand la plus grande espèce c'est le
grand cachalot et les baleines à fanons
dans le plus grand c'est le rorqual bleu
et et moby dick
c'est donc à cacher midi est un cachalot
d'un cachalot blanc d'accord et alors là
la différence c'est le néant le la
baleine et et le cachalot n'ont pas
exactement le même nez on le voit bien
là oui c'est à dire beaucoup de baleines
ont des néo différents tout état de
cause lit ce qu'on appelle les eaux
demptos est c'est à dire les cétacés à
dents pas seulement le cachalot c'est le
plus spectaculaire chez le cachalot et
notamment chez le cachalot mal mais on
le retrouve aussi chez d'autres espèces
aussi bien chez certains dauphin que
chez les globicéphales il y a
grosse tête ce qu'on appelle un melon et
ça a pris des proportions absolument
gigantesque chez le cachalot mal
probablement pour des raisons évolutive
liés à la communication et deux à la
prédation de très grands animaux vous
par de vrais si je continue de parler
baleines quand il s'agit de cachalot
voilà on va dire que c'est la même chose
pour ce qui nous occupe
les baleiniers au 19e siècle qui se
retrouvent dans ce que vous appelez la
guerre du pacifique est ce qu'ils sont
conscients qu'ils sont en guerre
absolument pas ils se rendent compte que
les choses sont plus compliquées que
dans l'atlantique et qu'elles le
deviennent de plus en plus mais pour eux
il s'agit d'une d'une pêche à la baleine
la pêche à la baleine a toujours été
dangereuse et elle le devient de plus en
plus mais il n'est pas question de
guerre à leurs yeux ils sont face à un
adversaire dont ils ne nous ont pas la
moindre imagination de ce qu'il peut des
actions coordonnées qu'il peut établir
bien sûr alors les baleines en revanche
quand on lit votre livre se dit elles l
ont compris l ont compris qu'il ya une
guerre et sept gardes vont l'amener et
elles vont l'amener avec beaucoup
d'intelligence collectivement mais
comment avez vous établi une une théorie
pareil parce que tous les exemples que
vous donnez sont assez frappant et ces
exemples ils sont documentés ils ont
vraiment existé il ya vraiment eu de
plus en plus de bateaux qui ont cure
disparus et pour bon nombre d'entre eux
on est à peu près sûr que c'est une
baleine qui s'est chargé de les faire
disparaître
mais à quel moment est ce que c est ce
que vous avez eu cette révélation alain
cndp un bon en tant que chercheur libre
sur les animaux sauvages
j'ai constaté qu'en fin de compte les
choses n'étaient pas si étonnante que ça
et même finalement assez banal parce
qu'en réalité bien sûr c'est cachalot
font la guerre parce qu'ils sont se
sentent très très directement concernés
ils ont une communauté à protéger
ou à disparaître et donc je me suis
plongé dans les dents les travaux moi je
ne fais pas de recherche particulière
sur la physiologie ou sur la biologie
des cachalots en tant qu' en tant que
chercheur je dirais pointu dans ce
domaine mais les revues des études de
plus en plus récentes sur la question
montre que ces animaux sont capables de
déployer une intelligence une
imagination et un système social
totalement inimaginable pour la culture
humaine jusqu'aux années 80 90
voilà donc le titre de mon livre est un
peu trompeur quand on parle d'
incroyable victoire des cachalots
elle est incroyable pour nous l
incroyable pour les humains mais pour
les cachalots il s'agit simplement
d'utiliser des choses qu'ils connaissent
beaucoup mieux que les baleiniers à
savoir les fosses océaniques proche des
continents les techniques de de
regroupement des femelles et des et des
jeunes dans des endroits à peu près
inaccessible aux baleiniers etc etc et
une attitude plus offensive mais à la
marge
même si c'est la seule qui a été retenue
pour mettre je dirais la la pression
morale sur leurs adversaires et alors
est sûre matin pourquoi est ce que cette
guerre les cachalots vont-ils les livrer
dans le pacifique et pas dans
l'atlantique où ils ont souffert
également est et pourquoi ces nantucket
que vous citez qui est pour vous une
superpuissance à l'époque un lille 2-1
tuque est où commence d'ailleurs moby
dick est en tout cas c'est dans
l'atlantique
et pourquoi est ce que ça va se passer
avec les américains et pas avec les
européens qui chassent et qui ont
chassés dès le xviiie siècle les
baleines autour des açores notamment de
façon souvent très violente 1 alors on
va passer assez vite sur le xviiie
siècle sur les 17e et 18e siècles
effectivement dans le xviie siècle c'est
d'abord les hollandais et un puits puis
puis les anglais les anglais vont
continuer d'ailleurs au 18e et dans une
grande partie du 19e siècle dans le
pacifique comme les américains mais à
une échelle infiniment moindres les
américains
ce que l'on sait relativement peu c'est
que le l'activité baleinière fondent les
états unis d'amérique en tant que tel et
donc notamment dans la région nord-est
dans la région de boston la nouvelle
angleterre et à nantucket
il va y avoir un développement encore
beaucoup plus important qu'ailleurs new
bedford ne viendra que dans un deuxième
temps une enquête va bientôt contrôlé va
posséder le plus grand empire du monde
de tous les temps
beaucoup plus vaste que celui de genghis
khan d'alexandre puisque ils vont
posséder les deux tiers de la surface
océanique dans un rapport de 80/20 avec
les autres bas ligne du monde entier ont
maigri inclus et donc les baleiniers
américain dans le pacifique et partent
de nantucket
à l'époque oui alors soyons soyons
précis nantucket en fait et très près
dominant dans la balle henrie américaine
jusqu'aux années 1820 en fait new
bedford deviendra le premier port
baleinier américain des 1823
mais les choses se verront je dirais
d'une certaine manière sûre sur le plan
un historique par les observateurs
extérieurs plutôt à partir des années
mais nantes kate aura en quelque sorte
de porter la légende de l'industrie
baleinière américaine et son activité
principale pour la deuxième moitié du
xviiie siècle et la première moitié du
19e assurément alors d'ailleurs dans le
tuc êtes vous le dit
la ville va brûler en 1846 et au moment
et puis carrément disparaître ensuite
vers 1860 et ils vendent le dernier
baleiniers 1869 le dernier baleiniers et
dans tuque était rayé de la liste des
des ports baleiniers mais ça a été une
telle ça a été un tel symbole jusque là
et on voit bien d'ailleurs que ça se
déplacent ça s'est déplacé dans le dans
le plat si fiq
alors votre votre guerre vous la situer
plus particulièrement entre 1820 et 1860
il faut voir que moby dick est publié en
1851 et pour vous mais biblique en fait
est un récit cacher nonna vous est pour
ainsi dire de cette guerre melville qui
est un écrivain absolument génial a
compris qu'ils aiment guère il la
raconte au fond oui si ça avec un bémol
moi je personnellement je ne suis pas
sûr que melville et conscientiser cette
guerre en tant que tel mais que en tant
que poète génial
il l'a senti il l'a pressenti son
instinct lui a dit qu'elle était là et
donc du même coup dans une formule
littéraire génial qui reprend la
structure de l'iliade en fait
melville induit que le récit fictif de
moby dick n'est pas malgré les
apparences et donc là les convictions de
l'équipage dubé code une chasse 2
du capitanat câble et du peak oil
obsessionnelle à la poursuite de moby
dick
mais en fait exactement le contraire et
avec des techniques qui sont totalement
différentes et précisément totalement
inimaginable pour le le pei cobb et son
équipage c'est à dire que moi je dirais
pour aller vite
les baleiniers américain chasse au
harpon les cachalots chasse au filet et
aux filets dérivants d'ampleur
planétaire
c'est à dire qu'ils attirent leurs
proies qui imaginent être leurs
prédateurs mais c'est faux ils attirent
leurs proies véreux par tout un tas de
signon de l'heure pour les en finir avec
eux dans une zone qu'ils ont préparé au
départ alors c'est ça qui est fascinant
dans votre récit c'est que non seulement
on s'aperçoit pas qu'à partir d'un
certain moment à partir de des années
1820 ça commence en fait avec le la
disparition de l'essex célèbre
baleiniers qu'on va voir apparaître
derrière moi les ex écoulé et une écoulé
par un cachalot il ya des juniors des
gravures d'époque qui montre les sexes
tel qu'il a été attaqué à ce moment-là à
partir de ceux de l'essex en fait les
grands cachalots combattants se retourne
contre les baleiniers et vont commencer
à les attaquer alors mené une guerre et
c'est au fond ce que raconte alors
conscient consciemment ou pas melville
quand il raconte que moby dick s'attaque
au p code peut-être plus que le pétrole
ne s'attaque à moby dick
oui après s'être attaqué à de nombreux
baleiniers des dizaines de balles signé
tel que le raconte le livre donc les
cachalots de du pacifique ont cette
particularité n'ont pas la même culture
que les cachalots de l'atlantique pour
les cachalots de l'atlantique sont
enchâssés il faut ils font ce qu'ils
peuvent je dirais ils ne sont pas
préparés à recevoir l'agression des
baleiniers les cachalots du pacifique
beaucoup plus parce qu'ils sont
confrontés depuis la nuit des temps à
des orques à des orc et polar qui sont
des baleines tueuses qui sont de grandes
baleines prédatrice un petit peu comme
des loups et les orques et polar de
l'atlantique sont piscivores ils mangent
du poisson donc ils vont pas s'attaquer
à des cachalots alors que dans le
pacifique c'est différent et donc du
même coup depuis des siècles et des
millénaires les cachalots ont développé
tout un tas de réponse vis-à-vis de ces
orgues qui attaque et c'est assez et ils
sont donc mieux préparés à la à
l'agression que leur fait subir les
baleiniers maintenant 1820 en fait on
n'en sait rien moi j'ai fixé ça un peu
arbitrairement
je ne suis pas sûr que cette cette
destruction du les sexes par le par le
grand cachalot marque un commencement
parce qu'en réalité dès le départ dès
l'arrivée de des baleiniers dans le
pacifique à la fin des années 1790 bubu
des années 1790 il se rend compte tout
de suite qu'ils ont des problèmes avec
des cachalots plus grand plus agressif
et dont ils considèrent qu'ils sont
isolés mais qui sont déjà coordonné en
quelque sorte
alors je pense que en fait c'est au
moment des années 10 1 dans les années
1810 1815 et notamment après la guerre
anglo american de 1812 1814 qui leur a
permis de souffler que là véritablement
prend une prise de conscience qu'il faut
qu'ils qu'il faut augmenter en échelle
il faut il faut je parle bien du côté
cachalot qu'il faut mettre sur pied des
plans beaucoup plus élaborée parce que
pour le moment on n'est pas très
efficace
on n'est pas suffisamment efficace pour
préserver nos populations alors
évidemment tout ça est et c'est une
vision que vous avez mais elle est très
pénétrante
les cachalots formerait une dation à ce
moment là une puissance en tant que tel
il y aurait comme des réunions
d'état-major puisqu'on sait que les
cachalots se retrouvent un certain
moment et qu'on sait qu'il communique on
sait qu'ils sont doués qu'ils ont des
sonars ce que n'avait pas les bateaux à
ce moment là on peut imaginer
en vous lisant effectivement que vous
avez mis le doigt dessus qui a une vrai
qu'il ya une vraie guerre à ce moment là
qui est menée par par ces grands
cachalots combattants dans l'ignorance
totale des baleiniers que évidemment ne
peuvent pas prêter à ces poissons même
géant de telles qualités et et par
surprise au fond part parce qu'ils en
agressivité une organisation et une
intelligence exceptionnelle
ils vont finir par les vaincre c'est à
dire qu'il y aura de plus en plus de
bateaux qui vont disparaître
vous les énumérer c'est extraordinaire
en face est extraordinaire pas pour les
marins de l'époque mais mais mais c'est
frappant oui les les baleinières les
bateaux qui vont à l'assaut des des
caches à londres ont toujours été
détruits y compris dans l'atlantique
mais les grands navires là c'est autre
chose
bon le premier c'est avec les sexes en
1820 mais à partir du milieu des années
1830 on a une une quantité
impressionnante de navires qui sont
écoulées sans compter je dirais les
ratages c'est-à-dire là où le cachalot
et tué parce que ça c'est important on
si parfois on réussit parfois on échoue
mais il faut voir le le niveau et le
degré si vous voulez d'implication de
ses cachalot mal qui a 4 avant d'avoir
été attaqué ce qui est quand même une
nouveauté et qui pose des problèmes
financiers économiques à toute
l'industrie baleinière avec les non
seulement les armateurs mais les
assureurs qui s'en mêle alors là on voit
un baleinier jeu derrière moi c'est les
sexes c'était quand même de très très
gros bateau ça n'aura plus évidemment
rien à voir avec ce que vont être les
baleiniers du 20e siècle et cela
malheureusement vont vont remporter la
guerre contre les contrôles et cachalots
et contre les baleines ce seront les
japonais à ce moment là et là il va y
avoir une véritable destruction de
l'espèce et aujourd'hui on les protège
justement que mais à l'époque il faut
voir que c'était déjà des monstres en
ces bateaux là et les baleines s'y
attaquent les lescoules lait coule
littéralement est-ce qu'elles sont
capables c'est ce que vous laissez
entendre et sont capables d'identifier
leurs cibles ah oui bien sûr oui oui et
non seulement elles sont capables de les
identifier de 2 206 200 souvenirs parce
que il y a plus ce sont des choses qui
s'inscrivent dans le temps long 1
ce sont souvent des animaux qui ont été
attaquées qui s'en sont sortis qui
retrouvent soit le même baleiniers soit
un autre parfois est le même et d'autres
et à chaque fois leur comportement safin
vis-à-vis de cela
par contre la taille des baleiniers des
navires baleiniers à l'époque elle est
pas si colossal que ça
le
les sexes au réel et le pcot de fictif
ne sont pas des six gros bateaux qui
sont plus gros cachalot ça assurément
mais ils sont pas si gros que ça par
exemple pour les sexes le second de
l'essex qui était le l'homme fort de
ceux de ce navire owen chaise va se
lancer dans une dans une vengeance
obsessionnelle contre les cachalots à
bord d'un navire beaucoup plus vaste qui
s'appellera le winx l'eau donc il va
prendre la précaution de bâtir un avenir
beaucoup plus vaste que que les sexes
grand devenir capitaine par exemple
alors ces réunions d'état-major auquel
vous faites allusion vous immerger elle
se serait passé comment y est il ya des
notions de secteur 1 chez les ch et les
grands cachalots de territoire tout
simplement
et à un moment il se retrouve alors le
vin contre la territorialité chez le
cachalot il faut pense bien penser que
c'est un humble sociale donc ça son
degré de territorialité nenê n'est pas
si élevé que cela il y a beaucoup de
migration il ya surtout beaucoup sur le
plan de l'organisation sociale les mâles
sont avec les femelles et les petits
pendant une période de l'année mais
pendant une autre période
ils utilisent ils migrent vers des
latitudes plus haute
c'est à dire que les femelles en général
un de façon statistique
les femelles et les jeunes vont rester
toute l'année en zones tropicales
subtropicales si vous lui alors que les
mâles soit par école de mal jeunes soit
par école de vieux mâles de des colts
cohorte si vous voulez vont eux se
retrouver pendant plusieurs mois de
l'année dans l'été arctique pour une
part pour certains d'entre eux et dans
l'été en arctique c'est-à-dire avec
évidemment six mois de différence pour
d'autres d'entre eux dans les régions
polaires
or on voit que les principaux conflits
de cette époque se déroule en zone
tropicale voir équatoriale c'est à dire
que les cachalots mal on
faites preuve prédéterminé planifier ce
que va être l'hiver polaire et l'été
équatoriale et ce dans les zones
polaires où ils sont intouchables à ce
moment là donc il s'agit tout simplement
de de base logistique de départ qui ne
peuvent pas être frappé par l'ennemi
en tout cas jusqu au moins au début des
années 1840 parce que les choses
évolueront ensuite les baleiniers iront
à la chasse de baleines franches
particulièrement heymans d'un type
particulier la baleine franche du
groenland qui atteint encore des
proportions encore plus vaste dans le
pacifique nord
alors qu'est-ce qui vous maire de guéret
qu'est ce qui vous permet de dire à la
scène pas que cette guerre a été gagnée
par les baleines sur les baleiniers au
19e siècle
il faut voir le quelle était la
situation début
et quelle était la situation à la fin au
début les processus mentaux psychologie
collective des cachalots n'était pas à
même de faire face à une agression dans
jusqu'au 1815 1819 nantucket c'est la
super puissance maritime mondiale en
1846 netiquette brûle en 1869 il ne lui
reste plus un seul navire
par contre en en ce temps les cachalots
ont maintenu et même vigo reese est un
secteur du pacifique particulier que les
baleiniers appelé le japan grogne qui se
situe entre les îles d'hawaï et les
côtes est du japon où les populations de
cachalot se sont regroupés ont essaimé à
partir de cette de cette nouvelle base
de ceux de ce nouveau sanctuaire
et où ils se sont maintenus à peu près
jusqu'à la fin des années 1940
ce qui veut dire que non seulement il
avait une protection géographique mais
que en plus cette culture acquise de la
guerre leur a permis de faire face tant
qu' elle n'a pas été massive à
l'industrie moderne avec les
navires-usines les canon lance harpon
tout ce qui concerne les inventions de
thomas souhait comme royce farine etc
etc sont de taux d'efficacité dans un
jeu jusqu'à l'épisode 2 du ii d'après la
guerre de 1946 mais jusque et la danse
dans ce cas là c'est parce qu'on va
bâtir énormément de bateaux absolument
immense et l'a totalement totalement
indestructible pour les cachalots
mais dans un premier temps les cachalots
vont les attaquer et il y aura des cas
où les navires baleiniers sort ont coulé
il y aura un navire soviétique qui sera
puni en 47 un navire norvégien en 63 il
y aura un navire japonais à une date que
j'ai oublié mais dans les années 50
donc si vous voulez ce processus de
guerre sera maintenu et ce qui aura été
un atout pour les cachalots dix neuvième
siècle sera un handicap pour eux au
cours de la deuxième moitié du xxème
parce qu'ils seront confrontés à un
adversaire tel et en utilisant une une
stratégie ancien en quelque sorte quoi
c'est un peu comme la france qui utilise
en 40
la même technique que caen 14 bon ben ça
marche pas deux font quasiment génocide
et deux derniers détails que vous faites
remarquer pour comprendre l'importance
même symbolique des cachets lourde tout
cas de l'industrie baleinière aux états
unis premièrement le mayflower sur
lequel arrivent les pèlerins les
premiers pèlerins aux etats unis c'est
un ancien baleiniers dites vous et puis
pinocchio la version 2
du de walt disney le dessin animé où on
voit pinocchio et gepetto se retrouver
dans le ventre d'une baleine dans le
roman de collodi c'était un requin c'est
une idée de walt disney une idée
américaine que de la voir transposer en
baleine
oui c'est une idée de walt disney le
requin de collodi absolument effrayant
un si vif et 13 13 mètres de haut un
kilomètre de long enfin bon j'en passe
et des meilleurs mais il n'en reste pas
moins que walt disney la la la
transformer en cash à l'eau ou plus
exactement en créature surréel cachalot
morte mais qui a des ddd fanon d'aider
des bandes comme les baleines aubeterre
et de manière plus significative encore
si vous voulez c'est que c'est le seul
dessin animé de walt disney qui ne
correspond pas du tout aux canons
habituels
c'est un film d'horreur il s'agit d'un
film d'horreur où le ou pinocchio et les
autres enfants vivent dans une terreur
explicite avec les yeux totalement
exorbités il se cache à l'eau n'est pas
un cachalot
c'est un monstre de l'enfer
le film est réalisé en 1940 un jeu
rappelle et la guerre contre les
japonais va bientôt venir et il y aura
une production littéraire spécifique ou
les cachalots légendaire du 19e siècle
seront tués
à ce moment là dans des petites
historiettes au moment où les loups les
japonais où on n'est pas encore à
guadalcanal c'est à dire où les japonais
risque concrètement deux conquérir
l'australie et de contrôler le pacifique
merci à la scène peint l'incroyable
victoire des cachalots dans leur guerre
contre les baleiniers au 19e siècle est
paru aux éditions de l'ondh
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]